revista de prensa en directo a mary que
ya está conmigo en el estudio rosa pérez
más de euros a qué bueno volver aquí al
programa luego de ya salir de la micro
en que me agarró la semana pasada rosa
me alegro que esté de vuelta a raúl a mí
también a más feliz año chino rosa el yo
20 y para celebrar no celebré esa
festividad bueno no por el momento todo
puede cambiar bueno vamos a ver qué pasa
entonces rosa hablemos de un tema no tan
amable vamos a méxico porque la semana
pasada estábamos comentando el tercer
asesinato un periodista en ese país y el
luto y la protesta del gremio hoy leemos
asesinan el periodista roberto toledo en
michoacán enero suma cuatro homicidios
contra los comunicadores esto es del
diario el proceso o rosa efectivamente
tal y como vemos bueno aquí en este
gráfico el proceso lleva en portada a
este asesinato contra el periodista
roberto toledo sin embargo en la imagen
que vemos aquí destacada vemos al
director del medio monitor michoacán
para el que trabajaba toledo durante el
comunicado que se retransmitió ayer en
directo a través de facebook y en el que
el director del medio reitero que desde
hacía tiempo las autoridades sabían que
el medio estaba recibiendo amenazas y ya
dijo literalmente tal y como recoge el
proceso hoy finalmente las amenazas se
cumplen y uno de nuestros compañeros
perdió la vida a mano de tres personas
que le dispararon de manera ruin de
manera cobarde nosotros no estamos
armados nosotros no traemos armas
nuestra única defensa es una pluma una
libreta y bueno recordar que además de
roberto toledo este mes de enero fueron
asesinados lourdes maldonado margarito
martínez y josé luís gamboa tres
periodistas también y en relación al
asesinato a los crímenes contra los
comunicadores cierra este artículo
diciendo diversas ong han documentado
que en los últimos 21 años
148 periodistas han sido asesinados en
méxico y afirman que el estado es el
principal agresor lo que hace el país de
acuerdo con comunicación e información
de la mujer el más peligroso del mundo
para el gremio triste rosa lo que
estamos hablando sobre estos asesinatos
y la violencia contra el gremio
periodístico en méxico seguimos en la
región pero cambiamos ahora radicalmente
de tema rosa vamos con un tema publicado
en la tercera de chile un análisis que
hizo juan andrés quezada se llama el
periodista se llama bórico versus
gabriel flancos abiertos del estilo
presidencial exacto porque bueno gabriel
boric aparte de que en el abanico
político está pues en el otro polo
respecto a su predecesor supone además
una cambio sobre todo en términos de
imagen de lo que es la política clásica
por lo que este análisis cuenta con
distintos expertos que opinan sobre como
el presidente electo electo de chile
puede hacerle frente a esta disyuntiva
dicen el mandatario ha enfrentado una
constante pugna entre su estilo informal
rockero y libre y las exigencias y
formalidades que conlleva la presidencia
aseguran que hasta ahora boric ha
llevado con mucho éxito esta dualidad
pero que a partir del 11 de marzo pues
puede tener que hacer algunos cambios
como por ejemplo citan no ser tan
impulsivo en twitter y es que hace
referencia a que boric salió en defensa
de la cantante pop
y lord swift en esta red social y dice
este texto que si bien fue aplaudido
como un símbolo de proximidad esta
defensa de la político a la cantante en
otros momentos de más intensidad y más
revuelo político podría haber sido
interpretado como un gesto un tanto
frívolo si bien hay un sociólogo eugenio
tironi que dice que es muy importante
para la sociedad el grado de
identificación que ha logrado por xxi
con las jóvenes que por cierto tengo mis
dudas yo todavía no sé decir la
pronunciación correcta es boric o boris
así que si nos están viendo algún
chileno les pedido que nos comente en
nuestros comentarios en youtube
bueno ahora comentamos al informe més
internacional que el gobierno israel no
quería que se publicara rosa y que
estamos hablando pues precisamente ayer
salió a la luz que la inteligencia de
tela viva había conseguido el informe de
amnistía internacional que hacía
referencia al apartheid el impuesto por
israel a la población palestina antes de
que saliera a la luz no porque el
informe ha salido hoy publicado y ayer
israel ya pedí a esta organización
nacional que no lo publicara si bien
amnistía internacional lo ha publicado
hoy y en este sentido pues van los
titulares internacionales como al
jazeera y también dejar es exacto pues
al yazira este medio catar y dice que
como comentábamos israel impone un
crimen de apartheid contra los
palestinos y debe ser responsabilizado
por tratarlos como una raza inferior
además en estas 25 páginas de informe
pues al yazira acoge algunos de los
abusos detallados como la expropiación
de territorios y propiedades ejecuciones
extrajudiciales drásticas restricciones
de movimiento detenciones
administrativas detención de la
ciudadanía o de la nacionalidad y haré
como de suyas también pues destaca que
la autoridad palestina
confirmó el informe a dijo que era una
descripción muy real de la crueldad bajo
la que vivía el pueblo palestino rosa
gracias entonces por esta revista de
prensa nos vemos mañana con más ahora
pasamos a saludar a nuestra primera
invitada al día